difficulties equals seals of the
EcoSport oven slow in Germany
our current system Michel Assenmacher
says so Ford has given it a facelift but
the changes lie in the details it
started to rain so we're gonna hop
inside the body has hardly changed but
Ford has revised it to make the Eco
sport more fun to drive on European
roads to date the model has done well
only in South America it's been
available from European dealers for 18
months but so far has failed to win over
buyers developers have realised that
Europeans view the Eco sport as a city
not an off-road vehicle so they revised
the suspension lowered the ride height
by 10 millimeters and retuned the
steering Michelle likes the SUV like
seat height the steering is a bit
squishy and she'd like more Road
feedback engineers have applied some
spit and polish to the interior they've
added chrome trim and high gloss piano
black finishes in the cockpit still the
4 inch screen feels outdated
nothing has changed in the trunk it
still holds 1240 liters
d glisten chill points out that the
biggest visible change is at the rear
where designers have dropped the
hatchback mounted spare wheel
the reason was aesthetic potential
buyers simply didn't like it so some
dealers went ahead and remove the spare
wheel themselves in the hope of making
the car more attractive the spare wheel
is still available as an extra feature
naturally at extra cost the Ford
EcoSport
has a Fiesta base chassis and is the
smallest member of the company's SUV
family the titanium version that we
tested comes with a silver colored roof
rack
the manufacturer says the one liter 92
kilowatt gasoline engine has a
consumption of 5.4 litres per 100
kilometers
the titanium version is priced around
20,000 800 euros in Germany
mrs. Michels verdict is that the Eco
sport doesn't have much pickup she needs
to keep it high up the rev range which
in turn increases gasoline consumption
nevertheless Ford says the 1 liter
EcoBoost engine is the most popular for
drivers looking for more than 92
kilowatts there is a new variant coming
out in the spring equipped with a more
powerful engine and sporty or designed
the S line is designed to broaden the
car's appeal
the show says if you're not after bells
and whistles but still want a cosy and
above all straightforward car then the
Eco sport is perfect for the starting
price at under 20,000 euros it offers
great value for money